I have some absolutely stunning an
incredibly disturbing video to play for
you today we've seen examples of just
about everything from the protests of
the last couple of weeks but today it
actually pains me to bring you this
video of police in Bethel Ohio almost
being more part of the mob than the
peacekeepers so I'm going to be playing
some video for you of a young man who
was protesting on behalf of the anti
police brutality movement whether we say
this was a black lives matter protester
or not doesn't really matter this was a
young white male that you're going to
see and in the video this man is at one
point surrounded by right-wing counter
protest protesters I guess we would call
them who seemed very unhappy with him
and at a certain point you also see two
police officers drift in and they're
standing right around this guy including
one one police officer right in front of
the camera a middle-aged white man with
an American flag bandana comes up behind
this protester winds up and punches the
guy in the back of the head right in
front of police officers the police
watch and do nothing to the perpetrators
perpetrator who violently attacked this
man when the young man who was assaulted
by police by the counter protester says
to the officer I was just assaulted what
are you going to do the officer does
nothing let's look at the video
apologies for those just listening today
I've done my best to describe what we
are going to hear and see the audio
doesn't tell the whole story so I
encourage you to find the clip online
for our video audience let's take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this has to be dealt with they said I
don't know the identity of the two
officers in question here I don't know
the identity of the perpetrator but
certainly with this video spreading
virally and the evidence plain as day on
the video they should be able to be
identified so what we need to do is
actually contact the Bethel Ohio Police
Department the Chief of Police that all
this information is public okay so I'm
not Daxing anybody the chief of police
is Steve Teague whose email which is
public is s as in Steve Teague te a gue
at Bethel - Ohio sorry Bethel - o H gov
B e th e L - o H gov the phone number
for the Bethel village Police Department
is five one three seven three four two
two five six we should be respectful but
we should be asking number one that the
attacker be identified and arrested and
number two that these two officers
actually be held to account for doing
absolutely nothing as a crime was
committed in front of them they must be
held accountable there are multiple
perpetrators here now more generally
what's been going on in Bethel Ohio has
been sick if you take a look at news
reports from the protests and counter
protests in Bethel the anti black lives
matter protest
SURS have been hurling racial slurs at
protesters intimidating them in one
video which I won't play today
a female counter protester approaches a
black protester and repeatedly calls her
the n-word / WCPO
local news in another video a counter
protester approaches a protester who is
white and uses anti black racial slurs
anyway and asks why are you even here
you are white so horrible stuff going on
in Bethel we should contact the police
department we should demand both that
the perpetrator be identified and held
to account but also the police who did
absolutely nothing and if you've been
experiencing this type of thing if
you've seen this where you live let me
know on Twitter I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and remember that you can get the
david pakman show audio podcast for free
every day on whatever your favorite
podcasting platform is be that be it
iTunes stitcher Google Play Spotify
wherever you want get the daily audio
podcast for the long-form version of the
show we'll take a quick break much more
is coming up today if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blink it's blink Isleta consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinka stinkiest has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about 8 bucks a month
and you get the entire library but you
can try it totally free and get 25% off
a subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video